We usually believe that the life we ​​live in is similar to that of others in general.
But did not you realize that most people in this world do not have Internet?
About 3.5 billion or just 40% of the world's population have an Internet connection today,
What makes this virtual reality that we live limited to a minority of people in the world.
And what about the fact that the majority of people in this world live in this circle?
In fact, it includes 22 out of 37 major cities, each containing at least 10 million people.
Only two cities in America are in this category: New York and Los Angeles.
On this basis, the majority of the world's population lives in developing countries.
Modern language, therefore, seeks to change terms such as "third world countries" to "the world's majority countries"
To accurately reflect the fact that these States are the majority of the human race,
Although the G-8 countries are making decisions that affect the majority of people on this planet.
As 70 to 80% of people earn less than $ 10 a day.
Even in a country as rich as America, more than 50% of its population earns less than $ 30,000 a year.
It is good that the global poverty rate has halved over the past decade.
But we still live in a world where people have more mobile phones than toilets.
When they talk about those phones, most do not speak English as a mother tongue.
The majority is not Christian as well.
According to the November 2016 census, males constitute the majority, with 55 million females missing.
The majority are under the age of 30 in our state.
In America, when it reaches 37, it officially becomes more than half the population.
What about the most common age globally?
Zero, followed by one year, two, three and four years, and then 26 years?
Most adults around the world weigh about 61 kilograms or 135 pounds.
While the vast majority in North America are obese.
While the majority of North Americans prefer coffee on tea,
We find that three cups of tea consumed for one cup of coffee globally, making it the most popular drink.
Speaking of North America, the majority of the Canadian people live south of Seattle.
In terms of energy consumption, the majority of the world consumes less than twice as much as the American or Canadian individual.
If we look more broadly, we will find that the basic component of the universe is 68% dark energy,
Dark matter accounts for 27%, and the rest includes everything on the earth and everything monitored by machines;
Which is called the ordinary matter, constitutes only 5% of the universe.
Since the atoms are made of 99.99% of the empty space, most of you is ... nothing.
Special thanks to Bill and Malinda Gates for taking care of this episode.
Did you know that child mortality has halved over the past 15 years?
And that the lives of 122 million children have been saved since 1990?
Sometimes you may feel that the world is heading for the worst, but global medical intervention changes that.
In their annual message, Bill and Melinda Gates seek to highlight this remarkable progress, and obstacles as well.
Such as the fact that 45% of child deaths are due to malnutrition.
You can see the annual letter at gatesletter.com through the link below to learn about and support their amazing initiatives.
Do not forget to sign up for more videos every week.
Translation: Team autrjim @.